Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à tous.
On va détendre un peu l’atmosphère :
on va parler de pipi,
de caca, c’est génial.
Ça va tous nous nous mettre
de bonne humeur.
Savez-vous ce qu’il se passe
sous vos pieds ?
Avez-vous une idée de ce qu’il se passe
lorsque vous ouvrez votre robinet,
lorsque vous tirez votre chasse d’eau ?
Pas forcément.
Ce n’est pas la première chose
qu’on se pose comme question.
Pourtant, comme l’a dit Assya juste avant,
c’est une mine d’informations.
On parle beaucoup de données, de data,
et de beaucoup [d’autres] choses.
Finalement, il y a des choses
que l’on partage,
il y a des choses dont on parle un peu,
peut-être pas comme on le devrait :
ce sont les données de notre santé.
Les données de notre santé,
on visualise ça comme les données
de ceux qui vont faire du footing.
Pas moi.
Les données de ceux
qui vont faire du yoga.
Toujours pas moi.
Mais finalement, les données de la santé,
ce sont aussi les données de notre corps,
les données physiologiques de notre corps.
Notre corps est une très,
très belle machine.
68 000 milliards de bactéries, 65 % d’eau.
Finalement, on est plutôt bien fait.
Et ce qui est encore mieux,
c’est que notre corps
a beaucoup de choses,
beaucoup, beaucoup de choses
à nous apprendre.
Aujourd’hui, lorsque nous tirons
notre chasse d’eau,
lorsque notre corps évolue,
beaucoup, beaucoup de choses vont
partir dans nos réseaux d’eau.
Les réseaux d’eau, parlons-en.
Avez-vous une idée comment ça fonctionne ?
Quand vous tirez votre chasse d’eau,
l’eau part dans une canalisation,
sous une maison ou sous un immeuble,
puis sous une route,
au travers d’une ville, d’une région
pour aller atterrir
dans une station d’épuration.
Cette station d'épuration va récupérer
tout ce qu'il y a, évidemment.
Je vous passe les détails.
Mais va mettre d’un côté de l’eau,
de l’autre côté des boues.
On va assainir tout ça,
on va nettoyer tout ça.
Les boues vont potentiellement
être réutilisées.
Ça peut servir à beaucoup de choses.
Et l'eau, finalement, va repartir
dans le milieu naturel.
Notre bonne vieille terre,
notre bon vieux vaisseau.
Finalement, c'est un bon retour
à l'envoyeur que l'on fait.
C’est plutôt pas mal, je trouve.
Je trouve que malgré tout,
c’est assez drôle
parce qu’il y a quand même une certaine
analogie avec notre corps
qui est d’une certaine manière, une espèce
de petite station d’épuration à son niveau
et donc, c’est assez proche, en tout cas,
du fonctionnement d’une station.
On a des rejets, ça passe
par l’estomac, l’intestin.
Finalement, on est très proche de
ce que l’on a nous-mêmes conçu.
Aujourd’hui,
et vous n’êtes pas tous sans savoir,
que la donnée, la data,
ça représente énormément d’informations.
Depuis 18 mois maintenant,
on traque le coronavirus
cette pandémie qui nous touche tous
depuis le début de l’année dernière.
On la traque dans les eaux usées,
on cherche les petits éléments dilués
qu’on peut retrouver dans des échantillons
de nos stations d’épuration.
Et grâce à ces données,
on essaye de suivre la progression,
la diminution également, de l’épidémie.
La plupart d’entre vous, vous utilisez
Facebook, Instagram, Snapchat.
Forcément, vous connaissez
le fameux adage :
« Si c’est gratuit,
c’est vous le produit. »
Je ne vais pas vous mentir, c’est vrai.
On ne va pas se mentir,
c’est tout à fait vrai et le cas.
Vous êtes le produit.
Pour autant, dans notre cas
de figure à nous, ce qui est intéressant,
c’est que cette donnée que nous pouvons
récupérer dans nos eaux usées
est une donnée globale.
Ce n’est pas une donnée nominative,
ce n’est pas une donnée,
comment dirait-on,
avec un nom, une adresse,
un numéro de téléphone, un e-mail.
C’est quelque chose qui
n’est pas intéressant.
Depuis maintenant 18 mois,
vous voyez la carte que certains voient
en fond d’écran ou derrière,
cette carte rythme
un petit peu nos nuits, nos jours,
on allume la télé, aujourd’hui
3 000 cas, demain 4 000 cas, 500 cas.
Finalement, on est un petit peu, comment
pourrait-on dire, spectateur
de cette carte météo.
Depuis 18 mois, nous sommes spectateurs
de cette épidémie qui nous touche tous,
qui nous a fait perdre des proches,
des amis, des collègues,
qui a endeuillé des familles entières.
Eh bien, étant donné que
nous sommes spectateurs,
il faut comprendre que
nous pouvons devenir acteurs.
Nous pouvons faire en sorte
de changer les choses.
Nous pouvons faire en sorte d'accélérer
les processus de détection.
À titre informatif, lorsque l’on fait
de la détection de pathogènes,
et là, je le mets
dans une grande catégorie,
quand nous faisons de la détection
de pathogènes dans les eaux usées,
en moyenne, à 14 jours d’avance, on est
capable de détecter les premières souches,
les premiers petits morceaux, pour
simplifier, de virus dans nos eaux usées.
Ce qui veut dire, 14 jours,
c’est gigantesque 14 jours.
On peut prévenir une population,
prévenir une agglomération,
ou prévenir une région.
Réussir à anticiper finalement,
parce que, comme je l’ai dit juste avant,
malheureusement, ce virus nous a pris
des personnes, c’est certain.
Mais ce virus nous a aussi pris du temps.
Ce virus nous a bloqués,
nous a fait rester chez nous.
Ce virus nous a obligés à restreindre
nos déplacements.
Finalement, ce virus nous a obligés
à restreindre nos libertés.
Ça, c'est quelque chose sur lequel
nous avons un impact.
Aujourd’hui, lorsque nous faisons
de la détection, par exemple de virus,
le coronavirus n’a pas le monopole
de nos angoisses ;
citation.
Pour autant, lorsque vous parlez
de grippe, de gastro,
ça peut porter à sourire.
Mais pour autant, ces épidémies, chaque
année touchent énormément de personnes.
Et là, je ne donne
qu’un florilège très local.
Dans d’autres pays,
il y a énormément de problèmes
de pandémies réguliers
dont on entend lointainement parler,
mais qui nous touchent très rarement,
desquels on est très éloignés.
Ça, c’est un problème.
Et comment nous faisons
aujourd’hui pour détecter ces virus ?
Eh bien, ce sont des petits capteurs,
des petits automates, des petits relevés.
Chacun a ses méthodes, peu importe.
Mais grâce à ces petits outils, nous
arrivons à faire le médecin des réseaux.
Nous allons vérifier le taux de graisse.
Nous allons vérifier
s’il n’y a pas de polluant,
vérifier si tout est bien fluide,
si rien n’est cassé,
si tout fonctionne bien
et on va réussir à sortir
un diagnostic un petit peu précis
de l’état de notre réseau.
L’état de notre réseau va nous permettre,
comme je le disais, 14 jours en avance,
de pouvoir détecter
et donc de pouvoir agir.
C’est ça, la première des choses.
Le fait de pouvoir agir
nous redonne le pouvoir,
nous permet de redevenir acteur
de ces pandémies.
Depuis 18 mois, comme je le disais,
de nombreux chercheurs
travaillent sur ce sujet.
Pour autant,
ce n’est pas quelque chose de nouveau.
Ce n’est pas qu’on a découvert d’un coup
qu’on pouvait détecter des choses
dans les réseaux d’eaux usées.
C'est fantastique.
Mais contrairement aux idées reçues,
ce n’est pas tout neuf.
C'est quelque chose d'assez ancien.
Il y a une chouette expression, je trouve,
qui est anglaise, qui dit :
«Flush it down the toilet »,
avec mon accent «French touch».
N’est-ce pas ?
On pourrait dire : jeter l’eau
par les fenêtres.
Depuis très longtemps,
très, très longtemps,
depuis une centaine d’années,
nous savons que nous pouvons détecter
des bactéries, des virus,
nous pouvons détecter une quantité
astronomique de matériel génétique
dans les eaux usées.
Néanmoins, depuis 100 ans,
à part notre grippe annuelle,
notre angine, éventuellement,
qui revient chaque année -
Vous savez, chaque année on est pris,
on se dit : «Quelle angine ! »
Cette année, vous avez remarqué,
avec les masques : pas de maladie.
Mais, pour autant,
depuis une centaine d’années,
on sait qu’on peut les détecter,
c’est possible.
Cette détection, on la retrouve
dans des livres qui datent de 1915, 1916,
où on nous dit : «La bonne détection
des bactéries dans les eaux usées.»
Vous imaginez ?
Que s’est-il passé en 100 ans ?
On n'a pas eu de pandémie,
pas de souci chez nous.
On n’a pas été embêtés énormément
pendant ces dix, quinze, vingt,
trente ou quarante dernières années.
Donc, depuis quarante ans, nos chercheurs
font de la recherche sur ces sujets-là
et on leur dit que c’est très intéressant,
mais qu’on ne sait pas à quoi ça sert.
Vraiment, ça ne nous aide pas.
J’ai toujours ma grippe chaque année,
ça ne sert à rien.
Donc, depuis toutes ces années,
on sait que ça fonctionne.
Mais pour autant, on a mis ça
dans les placards, on a jeté l’eau,
jeté la donnée de l’eau par nos fenêtres,
flush it down the toilet.
Il y a eu maintenant
quelque chose qui est important,
c’est que depuis 18 mois maintenant,
de nombreux pays se sont mis à détecter
le coronavirus dans les eaux usées.
De nombreuses initiatives publiques,
privées, universitaires
ont permis aux quatre coins de la planète,
aux quatre coins du monde,
de faire des détections
dans les eaux usées
en France, aux États-Unis,
en Australie et en Asie, partout.
On a eu des détections qui se sont
multipliées pendant toutes ces années,
enfin, pendant tous ces mois, plutôt.
Et finalement, aujourd'hui, on arrive
à comprendre l'intérêt.
Aujourd’hui, on arrive à comprendre que
détecter un pathogène,
ce n’est pas juste
pour faire joli et donner,
comme vous le voyez
sur les jolies petites diapos
qui sont à côté de moi,
ce n’est pas juste pour donner
de la donnée.
C’est pour permettre à tous
de pouvoir se dire,
sur cette zone territoriale,
sur cette région, sur cette ville,
il y a une recrudescence
de telle épidémie.
Nous pouvons protéger les gens,
nous pouvons protéger nos libertés.
Et pour la première fois
dans l’histoire de l’humanité,
ces données qui viennent de nos eaux usées
ont permis à des gouvernements,
à des régions, à des communes de prendre
des décisions de confinement,
de non-confinement,
ont permis aux gens d’avoir un socle,
un périmètre de sécurité autour d’eux
et de faire en sorte
de pouvoir adapter la réponse
en fonction des problèmes que
nous avons rencontrés
et des solutions que nous avons trouvées.
Alors, ce que je vous propose aujourd’hui,
finalement, tous ensemble,
c’est d’arrêter de
«flush it down the toilet »,
de reprendre un peu la main
sur nos robinets, nos chasses d’eau,
de comprendre
un peu comment ça fonctionne
et d’aller chercher plus loin pour gagner
demain le choc des titans
de nos réseaux d’eau et de notre corps.
Merci à tous.
(Applaudissements)